first change the writer and star of
notes from the field premiering February
24th on HBO Anna deavere Smith
[Music]
[Applause]
I can do that
the current Eric and I we can still
greet each other with a kiss on the
cheek yes oh good thank you
so listen dear shows pretty amazing what
you do is pretty amazing you can be so
many different people in the space of
two hours a lot of what you're talking
about now is I guess what they would
call the school to Prison Pipeline yes
and I certainly thought of it yes this
week after the the shooting because you
know when you learn about what goes on
we seem to when somebody some kid is in
trouble
we push them away we don't bring them in
and once they get in that prison system
it never gets better right right so the
school to Prison Pipeline I think really
came to more sort of public
consciousness during the Obama years
Justice Department had data to show that
black brown Native American and also
poor white children are disciplined more
harshly than their middle class and and
upper-class cohorts a lot of things that
a kid might do in school that a white
kid would it be called mischief you know
and poor kids get pathologize and sent
to jail and it really starts with
expulsion and with suspensions they
actually you could figure out about when
a certain number of suspensions might
predict that a kid is going to end up in
juvenile hall and then from there into
that cycle of mass incarceration which
of course destroys communities and
families and everything else you know
you brought up the recent events in a
high school and one of the things about
that is that Nicholas Cruz was expelled
and schools have a lot of limitations we
want to criticize schools I'm I'm not so
happy after 250 interviews in four
geographic areas that I even sort of
call my project about the school to
Prison Pipeline because what you find
out is that it's really poverty that
begins to fritter away a people's lives
but having said that you know he was a
he he left school and once he left
school there was nowhere for him to go
and if he was able to get any kind of
mental health services in school you
know he was just on the loose right and
it just I mean it can happen anywhere
somebody once said to me
you know there's schools in this country
that look like prisons big nose and
those kids are more likely to wind up in
prison and there are high schools that
look like colleges and those kids more
likely go to college that's right but
not always and we got to get we got to
get all the schools to look like
colleges or I think schools will have to
become something like community centers
where people can get multiple services
parents need to be in there and and you
know I so often teachers get blamed for
the problems that we have right now but
you know I think more schools are going
to look like prisons given these recent
events of course and Trump is taking
away more money from of course you know
all the money had to go to the rich
people's tax cut so everything gets cut
but you know you play a lot of men
sometimes in your shows but it's right
about half and half but you know if you
if you sometimes in this culture if you
play something that you're not they get
mad at you you know like if you're a
white person you play in a and they say
that should have good you you hear that
from men like how dare you well you know
I don't actually know and I don't know
it may be one of the few benefits of
being a african-american that I'm less
likely to get in trouble for playing you
than you would for playing me so what
right
so what was your favorite man to play
currently in this show you know I don't
really have favorites but I do I think
let's just say that I think well first
of all John Lewis I play Congressman
John Lewis that he ends the whole play
and my plays my plays usually start with
outrage and then they go to a sort of
form of mourning and then they usually
end up with love or forgiveness and John
Lewis really after this whole play of
seeing violent acts like even on your
show you covered some of the things that
I was interested in the kid from Texas
in a pool party who was thrown across
the lawn by a big cop young Chikara in
in Columbia South Carolina thrown across
getting try a big big football coach cop
trying to get her out of her chair
throwing across the room and even
Freddie gray so after all of these kinds
of images that are very troubling I try
to bring it all home with acts of
courage Bree Newsome who climbed the the
flagpole to bring down the Confederate
flag after the Charleston massacre and
then for John Lewis so I mean I think to
tell these stories of this country you
have to tell it through the voices of
many people not just one race and not
just one gender
you mentioned Freddie gray those those
cups are there were six of them they
were all acquitted and they're all
working again and three of them are
african-american so that's that's an
interesting I don't think the race of
the cop really matters so much that's
what I'm saying because they're in this
system that I don't I don't understand
how they think but they're they're
working for a system which has roots a
long time ago you know there was a
famous prison called Parchman farm in
Mississippi that pretty much was
behaving just like slavery and and
people the convicts had to grow crops
and they were very profitable and the
people who walked around with guns
really keeping an eye on these worker
prisoners were black men called trustees
sometimes they have been murderers
so it's not a new thing that we would
have black cops or black people in that
position cops are all about protecting
property well I think they would
probably say they would they would want
to extend that a little to protecting
people well people with property you've
worked as a professor what do you make
of the kids today the crazy hair in the
ya-ya music well it's not about it's not
about the crazy hair in the year yeah
music I mean I've been teaching for a
long time so I can't confess how long
ago you'll know really how old I am but
I have three words for you Bill Maher
$90,000 that's what it costs go to film
school at NYU where I currently teach
okay first of all we don't need anyone
in film school well we have enough
filmmakers but people this has got to
end
we got it we've got to get the kids
studying real [ __ ] okay if you want to
be a filmmaker you will find your way to
do it the arts does not need the help
with the government I know that's a
conservative position you probably hate
it but that's my view well I think the
government needs the help of the arts
[Applause]
$90,000 yes yeah well I mean look
college that's gonna be a big issue in
the next election Democrats want free
college and they want single-payer they
want some real high ticket items but
they don't have the balls to say you
know where the money is the Pentagon
defense really means defense contractors
that's where the money is that we need
to get to fix the things in America that
need to be fixed that would actually
make us say well what notes for the
field is about really is that the
question I posed is about investments
you know what are we going to invest in
and in my case I'm asking are we going
to invest in education are we going to
invest in prisons and it's now certainly
headed to the prison side are we going
to invest in mental health or are we
going to invest in prisons it's leaning
towards the prison side and we have a
country for Veck Marty who was at one
point our Surgeon General went around
the country and he interviewed a lot of
people he found out this is a country in
pain not physical pain emotional pain so
true gonna continue that it right over
there thank you so much you're such a
pleasure to talk
[Applause]